pour la 5e fois de son histoire Paris
Nice s'élancera des Yvelines l'édition
2014 de la course du soleil partira de
Monte la jolie pour une première étape
longue de 162 km avant de retrouver la
ville de Rambouillet le département
semble devenir la terre promise du
cyclisme pourtant le peloton ne passera
pas devant le vélodrome national de 50
ans en Yveline oui mais on l'a beaucoup
vu là pour l'inauguration et puis faut
laisser le temps je pense également à
l'équipement de ce roder hein
l'inauguration vient de se dérouiller il
a quelques jours bon voilà il faut qu'il
prenne je dire son rythme de croisière
il y a encore des aménagements
intérieurs à achever il y aura toujours
quelque chose de nouveau dans le
département des ivin dans le domaine
cyclisme indéiablement grâce à cet
outils performant au cours de cette 72e
édition il n'y aura ni prologue ni
contre la montre une première depuis
près de 60 ans h étapes en ligne sont
donc au programme qui devrait sourir au
baroueur et au puncher François Le
Marchand a tracé un parcours où tout
vraiment se jouer partout les quelques
secondes grappillé au mur de faillance
dans la montée de bruit les quelques
minutes peut-être pris en allant vers le
département de Lyonne dans le vent
feront que il y aura du suspense
jusqu'au bout mais je crois que ça ouvre
la course à toutes catégorie de coureurs
qui n'ont peut-être même jamais rêvé de
gagner Paris et qui vont se retrouver
pourquoi pas au première loge le mois
prochain on souhaite que ce soit une
course ouverte avec des gens qui osent
et qui a une prime vraiment aux
audacieux c'est fait pour je suis bien
incapable de vous dire qui va gagner
parce que il n'y a pas les les
références classiques d'un chrono qui
permet au favoris de se jauger ou d'une
arrivée classique en altitude quiexiste
pas non plus l'Australien rich défendra
son titre côté Français Sylvain Chavanel
3e en 2009 aura toutes ses chances et
les espoir Nasser BO et BR C viseront
certainement des victoires d'étape
verdict à partir du 9 mars
prochain